and we have leang Liam here with us Liam
hello and welcome to the studio it's
really nice to see you here and it's um
third time that you're participating in
St Louis rabbit and Blitz how did it
feel to play today in the Hall of Fame
yeah it's always a pleasure to be here
playing in this strong tournament and I
think today I couldn't ask for a better
start absolutely two and a half out of
three and it could have been even better
if you would win this in the second
round right so but let's let's check the
game one uh where you played against
wesle so I think there was really
interesting moment around this this time
can you please check what when I play uh
this Knight E4 I thought he would just
take on e4 and Bishop E4 Queen D6 and
it's very dsh um I can wait I can play
Rook C1 and nothing much is happening
here I think it should be a draw and
then he got a bit ambitious I guess and
he played this move um Queen G6 and then
I have this Knight C5 so now after
Bishop F5 is already a little bit tricky
because after Knight D7 he told me he
missed this move I I think so Knight D7
is easy to miss right yeah yeah uh the
thing is that black wants to play F6 but
this move is uh is a little bit uh
tricky let's say I go here and then I
potentially have D6 as well
so and he was a little bit low on time
so he couldn't evaluate it so I think he
from this moment he um didn't fight a
best move and then I I managed to win
this um after D6 I think it's already
winning uh I had Knight F6 here as well
but I thought Queen F5 first is more
accurate because I'm threatening Knight
E5 on Knight F6 now so uh he I think
it's going lost when did you see this
idea Knight F6 let's show it it's such a
brilliant Mo move that I mean I'm ready
to show it again I mean Knight F6 here
yes at the end look yeah so I I had this
idea the entire time when I play after
D6 I already saw that I have ideas is
like moving the Knight and then D7
the two Rooks uh but here really
works best because if I if I play Knight
F6 here MH um what is the difference uh
the difference is that black still the
E5 Pawn is is easier to defend on E5 so
it should be still winning for white but
it may take a little bit more time and
the difference in the game is that the
pawn on e4 is a much is much weaker and
after I I go here this7 um I don't think
there a defense for black for example
black might play F5 but okay I can go
like Rook D5 uh Knight E7 let's say Rook
E5 and then um potentially I'll go G4
later it's really nice that both Rooks
keep hanging I don't have to take them
need even to take them immediately this
is really cool um so let's go to check
the the other games let's go for the one
you won I mean the third round right so
um let's have a look we just finished
right now against jeffre J well let's go
to some critical moments so um I think I
misplay the uh opening of the middle
game a little bit around here I thought
I had um very decent position I think
I'm supposed to take on C6 like this and
go Knight E5 and then Rook H3 ideas
Queen G4 Queen H5 and white should have
a small pressure but um the way it
happened in the game it was just equal I
I thought um at this point he was
repeating the move and I could have
taken a draw but I thought okay let's
let's play a little bit and see what
happens yeah that was an interesting
moment our commentators were discussing
I mean did you want just to repeat the
position once or you were really
thinking to to make a draw well usually
um you know in in this moments it
doesn't hurt to repeat once and get some
time and see what your opponent's
attention so you have this habit yes of
repeating um yeah yeah I think it's a
good habit also it's kind of you know
shows who is in charge this position
because I'm the only one who is deciding
to play on here of course it wasn't much
um I think somewhere around here uh yes
this is the critical moment after C4 I
took DC and here he should have just
taken back with BC and then I was
planning que4 and then just he can have
Rook C8 and this is
um very Rish is eventually we on
the yeah but G5 is potentially weak so
so the problem is that uh I think he
missed this move after King E2 BC and
then I have Bishop E3 and this is
already a little bit tricky um I see
that the engine here says black and Horn
with Bishop Tes E3 Rook Tes E3 and some
move like King F7 mhm but yeah it's it's
still a pawn um a pawn down for black so
it wasn't so easy and the way I play
after Bishop E3 he didn't take and that
was just losing from black so I would
say I was a little bit Lucky in this
game um but uh that kind of compensated
for the second game where I couldn't win
yes yes exactly it was so winning at the
end I mean coming first day two and a
half points um is it important for you
to start well the tournament I think so
I think in the tournaments that I got a
good result usually I start very well um
so definitely that's a good start but
it's only the first day and I will play
um all the other opponents are still
super strong so I don't expect any easy
day
yeah exactly thank you so much for your
comments and I think it's time to go
back to the studio if nobody has
questions thank you Anastasia our
congratulations to a very uh deserving
uh first place uh